[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight the commerce department
today announced changes to the census
ordinarily that would not be a very big
deal starting in two years respondents
will be asked if they're US citizens
that question has been asked on census
forms in years past and there are
obvious reasons for asking it the main
point of the census this is what a
Constitution requires it is to apportion
congressional districts so Americans can
vote for their representatives only US
citizens are allowed to vote in federal
elections so it might be nice to know
how many live in this country sound
reasonable to you even boring are you
still awake if not then you're not a
professional outrage merchant the left
came close to losing consciousness
today over this idea the Attorney
General of California Xavier Becerra
says he will sue the Trump
administration over this change Becerra
claims that asking people whether or not
they're citizens is somehow
unconstitutional launched given the way
that this administration has attacked
immigrants
you can understand why immigrant
families would be afraid to fill out the
census questionnaire in our lawsuit we
argue that this decision by the Trump
administration violates the Constitution
and federal law well Ari Berman and
Mother Jones magazine is even madder
than Xavier Becerra from an apparently
misplaced his xanax this morning he got
so worked up about the census question
he described a change as quote a huge
crisis for democracy no come on nobody
actually believes that nobody believes
lines like that even the red-faced
people who scream them the left doesn't
care about what is or what is not
constitutional did you watch the gun
March this weekend obviously they don't
care a crisis for democracy if you
really cared about democracy
representative democracy
you'd be vigilant about preventing voter
fraud instead the left actively abets it
in state after state including
California where illegals get driver's
licenses and can register to vote
democracy please what progressives
really care about is power they hate the
fact that you took some of their power
by voting for Donald Trump and they want
it back by any means necessary that's
what this is about
obviously Cesar Vargas is an attorney
and an illegal immigrant and he joins us
tonight Cesar thanks for coming on tell
me what they could have of me counting
your citizens asking whether they are
citizens how could that be
unconstitutional when the Constitution
requires that you count your citizens
well we're talking about the
Constitution right and Republicans and
conservatives are all about the original
intent the founding meaning of the
Constitution well the Constitution
explicitly states that we need an actual
enumeration in other words or an actual
account of the whole persons in each
state never said anything about
immigration status never said anything
the purpose is to count everyone in the
United States regardless of the
immigration is that so that's perfect as
a person of who approves of original
intent you would understand that that we
would need to count everything and I
know I know I know your leg should be
the Constitution but does this change
say that you're not allowed to count
people who are non-citizens no it says
take account of it it's one of them any
questions the Constitution by the way
since I know you're so familiar with it
doesn't say anything about
counting people by race this census does
that are you opposed to that should we
not ask for people's races well under
this administration we have been very
clear that it's about targeting
immigrants when the president said don't
stop stop stop I want you to answer my
question because I think it's a fair
question you don't think that the census
form ought to be allowed to ask people
whether they're here legally or whether
they're citizens aren't okay but you do
think it ought to be allowed to ask them
what their genetic makeup is with the
races why well I think we should
definitely have a very simple document
that says hey how many people live in
your home how many people have an
opportunity to live in the state I think
that's simple I don't I'm not putting
aside the politics what about the race
what about the race the census asks what
your race is I think it's creepy as hell
to be honest so this has nothing to do
with any choice that you made something
you're born with but the census asks it
and it asks because the left demands
that it ask it do you think the census
ought to be allowed to ask people's race
well I think we should have a simple
count that's it men and maybe no I think
we shouldn't have immigration status we
shouldn't have about race we should I
say hey how many people live in your in
your house that's it that's what the
Constitution requires it's all about
allocation whatever a person male or
female should ask that should be loud is
that unconstitutional too well I think
if a person wants to designate hey I'm a
male I'm a female let them let them as
well watch woman but that that was the
question the census asks are you a man
or a woman are you
non-hispanic white are you African
American are you American Indian and now
it's gonna ask are you a citizen only
one of those questions bothers you not
because of the constitutionality of it
but because you think it might dilute
the political power of illegal aliens no
no stop the Constitution because it's
not with you that it should be about
counting people based on people not
about representation somewhere difficult
or not it's restricting race
the Constitution says hey we just need
to count people if you're a male or if
you're female great representation sorry
down why is it a difference it's a
different story because you think it
might dilute the political power of
illegal aliens who I could add I'm not a
lawyer like you shouldn't be here in the
first place
but you're not bothered by sex or race
so let's just stop pretending let's drop
the facade let's stop playing the stupid
game we pretend it's about your concerns
about the constitution of a country
you're not even allowed to be in because
you're I think you're here illegally too
so let's just say this is about pure
political power it's about one side
trying to take back power from the other
and like let's be adults about it can we
do that or do you want to go as pretty
that shows that that's a concern of your
views that's the concern of you that
you're afraid that if you count on
document immigrants that's going to
dilute your power it's not about power
it's about simple representation the
fundamental principle mystery agents
it's about equal representation okay
citizenship is the basis upon which we
determine political power citizens have
political power non-citizens don't
that's the difference if you want to
distill citizenship to a sentence there
you have it and so yes I do want to
dilute the political power of the
citizens of other countries I don't
think that Russian citizens are Nigerian
citizens or citizens from the Seychelles
ought to be allowed to vote in my
elections that that's constitutional
it's a definition of constitutional well
that's not what America stands for what
America stands for is that you can be a
hundred percent American but you can be
100 percent Mexican African and Mexican
citizenship and French citizenship crazy
thing about how beautiful these
countries but you're not allowed to not
have citizenship and vote which leads to
a question I mean to ask you for some
time as we've been abetting your illegal
stay here in this country do you plan to
vote in the next election I think you
live in California they'll let you vote
it's illegal do you plan to do it anyway
based on the theory you just elucidated
for the rest of us well we're talking
about counting I do think that every
person should you get now no question
about universal I do believe that we
should have universal voting for
everyone to ensure that everyone has
citizens of other countries so I'm
laughing public this should be able to
vote here no taxation without
representation who comes to the United
States and buys a deck of marbles and
pays the sales tax is entitled to vote
that's what you're saying if that person
comes to you to contribute to the
country let him have a say in his
government let foreigners vote I hope
the Democratic Party runs on that I
think it'd be a fun election Caesar
thank you for being honest
thank you for my tea take care Chris
Kobach is the Secretary of State of the
state of Kansas he's been following
these issues closely because he cares
and he joins us tonight
mr. secretary thanks for coming on so
you know explain to us why it's
important to know whether or not people
counted by the census are American
citizens there are a million reasons why
the first and foremost is that any
sovereign nation needs to know how many
citizens it has the second is that all
kinds of Statistics require us like an
unemployment statistics knowing how many
of the people in the United States are
citizens and how many are non-citizens
meaning aliens both legal and illegal we
have to know that and then apportionment
if Congress decides as it should to stop
counting illegal aliens we need to know
exactly how many are in each category I
mean it's absurd that states like
California have an inflated number of
representatives in Congress because they
have so many illegal aliens in this so
you know there's so many reasons but let
me just quickly respond to your previous
guest I couldn't stop laughing
his notion that it's unconstitutional to
count citizens as people if their
citizens are not look we started doing
this in the 1820 census the founding
fathers were still alive in 1820 if it
was unconstitutional to ask are you a
citizen they would have said hey don't
ask the citizenship question that's
unconstitutional the second thing is the
Supreme Court ruled in 1964 and
westberry versus Sanders that diluting
the votes of US citizens which is what
happens when you count the illegal
aliens in a district that is
unconstitutional so wonder if kid
serves make a mistake in having
constitutional arguments of people who
think the Constitution is fundamentally
illegitimate because it was written by
slave owners in the first place I mean
this really has nothing to do with the
Constitution
I doubt Xavier Becerra is knows what's
in the Constitution he doesn't care this
is all sophism it's demagoguery designed
to take power from people they don't
think should have it voters do you think
well I yeah I think so and you hit the
nail on the head when you said look it's
all about power that's why the left is
apoplectic about the notion that we
would be counting citizens again like
we've done through most of our country's
history because they they see that this
potentially could threaten the inflated
number of congressional seats but again
the Trump administration can't do it
unilaterally it would take an act of
Congress next to say okay apportionment
should not count illegal aliens but we
should have done that decades ago by the
way that's for sure that and a lot of
other things let's go back thank you for
joining us great to see you my pleasure